Salut, il y a quelques jours, j'ai eu une bonne idée
enfin que je croyais avoir eu une bonne idée
Je me suis dit: "tiens les jeudis maintenant, dans le MentalVlog, je vais faire un nouveau format.
Je vais parler des trucs qui me passionne, des trucs que j'aime bien
et je vais prendre le temps de les écrire, de faire un truc bien construit
Je vous en ai parlé dimanche sur la chaîne YouTube, vous avez dit: Oui pourquoi pas, c'est une bonne idée, vas-y, faut essayer, faut voir ce que ça donne
Je viens de taper dans le pied de caméra
Forcément j'ai eu tous ces commentaires là lundi soir.
Le début de semaine a été un petit peu speed
et là je me suis dis Fabien,
tu as encore eu une idée brillante.
Parce qu'on est jeudi et que j'ai pas eu le temps d'aller au bout de ce que je voulais faire
j'ai pas eu le temps d'aller au bout de l'écriture en fait
Et je ne veux pas vous donner un truc bâclé
Là je suis à peu près dans le même rythme qu'hier. Il est 15h et j'ai pas encore fait la vidéo, enfin si je suis en  train de la faire
Oulala, ça mon pote c'est de la mise en abîme
Je me suis aussi rappelé que je vous avais dit que le jeudi ça serait un peu du "je fais comme je veux, je vous parle de ce que j'ai envie"
Tout en restant dans le mentalisme je vais vous parler un petit peu plus de moi dans le sens
ce qui me fait rire, ce que j'aime, ce qui m'interpelle en fait vraiment
Donc le résultat de tout ça.
C'est que je vais continuer à écrire la vidéo que je voulais faire aujourd'hui
pour jeudi prochain
Et pour aujourd'hui, je vais vous parler de 2 jeux que j'aime beaucoup
dont un des 2 jeux que vous voyez souvent ici : Black Stories et un autre que vous ne voyez pas parce qu'il est dans une autre pièce
ATTENTION ce n'est pas du placement de produit
On ne m'a pas offert ces jeux. Enfin si, les deux on me les a offert mais c'est des amis qui me les ont offert, ça n'a rien à voir
Tiens ce sont des amis que vous connaissez d'ailleurs, je vous dirai à chaque fois qui m'a offert quoi
Euh... Bon je commence par Black Stories qui est édité par Kikigagne. C'est une boite de jeux que je ne connais pas.
Ah oui, y'a ça quand même, parce que je connais beaucoup de boite de jeux.
C'est vrai que je ne vous ai pas précisé ça. Je suis joueur, j'adore jouer, j'adore tous les jeux d'une manière générale
que ce soit un jeu de carte, une jeu de plateau, un jeu de rôle. Je suis joueur dans l'âme en fait
Je suis gamer dans l'âme mais pas forcément sur les jeux électronique en fait
Les jeux électroniques... Fabien tu as 1000 ans, on l'avais vu dans tes poils de barbe hier qui sont devenus tout blanc récemment
*chuchote* Mes poils de barbe sont devenus blanc
C'est pour ça que je me suis rasé aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
Voilà je suis joueur, j'aime jouer et j'aime avoir des amis joueur
et je trouve qu'on découvre vraiment une personne, qu'on rencontre réellement une personne quand on fait un jeu avec elle
que ce soit des amis ou autres, c'est toujours chouette de faire un jeu en fin de soirée.
D'ailleurs, j'ai relevé un commentaire qui était super intéressant pour une des astuces du mercredi
Le jeu du post it
Quelles astuces pour gagner, je vais vous faire une vidéo là dessus, peut être même mercredi prochain tiens
Cette vidéo devient n'importe quoi parce que je fais des parenthèses, dans les parenthèses, dans les parenthèses, que je ne referme jamais
Reprenons donc sur Black Stories aux éditions Kikigagne
C'est Jeanne qui me l'as offert, vous savez de Jeanne fait son cinéma
souvenez vous ça devait être la 3ème ou 4ème vidéos que j'ai fait cette année
On est à combien aujourd'hui 56 je crois bien
Alors c'est un jeu qui se joue à 2 au minimum et à 25 au maximum
En réalité, vous jouez à autant que vous voulez peu importe
mais ça peut se faire à 2
et ça peut même se faire avec quelqu'un qui n'a pas envie de jouer
ça c'est cool, ça peux être juste vous qui jouiez réellement
Pourquoi parce qu'à l'intérieur de cette boite, il y a 50 histoires, 50 Black Stories
euh... je vais vous en faire voir une. Voilà qui est comme ceci
Donc il y a un dessin, y'a un titre et y'a une petite phrase
Là, c'est : Un voleur très recherché, se rendit à la police mais il ne fut pas arrêter. Plus jamais
Et, de l'autre côté de la carte, il y a toute l'histoire en fait
qui est racontée. Toute l'histoire, sur la personne, alors là c'est l'histoire de Vidocq en réalité
je sais pas si vous connaissez son histoire. Mais c'est une histoire vraie à chaque fois, une histoire lugubre: Une Black Storie
qui est nourrie de pleins de détails, de dates, d'explications sur ce qui c'est passé
et pourquoi ça c'est passé, comment la personne le faisait
Et vous allez me dire comment ça se joue
Allez y dites le. A 2 personnes, les rôles sont clairement définis. De toute manière à plusieurs c'est pareil
Il y a une personne qui va devenir le maître de l’énigme
Le maître de l’énigme prend l’énigme, parce que c'est le maître hein
et prend connaissance de toute l'histoire qu'il y a derrière, c'est une histoire que la personne va devoir maîtriser
mais elle l'aura sous les yeux tout le long
et aux joueurs, donc au joueur(s) au singulier ou au pluriel
le maître de l’énigme va lire l'énoncé qu'il y a ici
Un voleur très recherché, se rendit à la police mais il ne fut pas arrêter. Plus jamais
Et il va rajouter la phrase: Mais pourquoi dont?
A partir de ce pourquoi dont, le joueur ou les joueurs vont poser des questions au maître de l’énigme
Des questions auxquelles on ne peut répondre uniquement que par oui ou par non
si c'est pas le cas le maître de l'énigme fait reformuler
Les joueurs vont émettre des hypothèses
il va y avoir une espèce d'entonnoir, tout est possible au départ
il va falloir resserrer les hypothèses, resserrer les hypothèses, jusqu'à temps de pouvoir expliquer pourquoi "Un voleur très recherché, se rendit à la police mais il ne fut pas arrêter. Plus jamais"
donc pourquoi
ce voleur qui c'est pourtant rendu à la police, ne fut plus arrêter, plus jamais arrêter
il y a pleins de manière d'y jouer, c'est ça qui est intéressant plus on est nombreux,
plus on a une manière de réfléchir qui est différente
et plus on va attaquer par des angles différents
Sur cette énigme là, en particulier, on pourrait émettre des 1ères hypothèses pour essayer de chercher pourquoi il s'est rendu à la police, en fait
qu'est ce qui a fait qu'il se rende à la Police
On pourrait aussi dans un 1er temps, chercher à quelle époque, ou à quel endroit ce sont déroulé les faits
Et, c'est ça qui est franchement génial
C'est qu'à chaque fois, il y a une phrase qui... qui ne mène à rien
et ça finis par pourquoi dont?
Tout est possible, tout est imaginable. Et on créait un rail de réflexion
et à la fin on trouve le pourquoi. Quand c'est fait, le maître de l'énigme nous donne la carte ou lis l'histoire à tous les joueurs si on joue ça à plusieurs
C'est super quand tu bois un coup euh... avec du monde ou euh... quand on est plusieurs dans les transport en commun et qu'on s'embête
C'est... c'est un jeu qui nécessite rien en fait, c'est ça qui est cool
après le maître de l'énigme peut décider que l'énigme est entre guillemet résolu si les joueurs ont trouvé de quel crime célèbre on parlait ou de quel personnage historique on parle
puisque cette édition là en particulier est basée sur des faits réels
Y'a 50 énigmes différentes, y'a la petite règle du jeu, la boite est très sympathique
personnellement, je vais me procurer les autres éditions. Je vous le conseille. C'est cool
Et je le remet à sa place
Une des choses intéressantes avec ce genre de jeu c'est qu'on peut y jouer à 2.
C'est quand même assez rare, en fait, les jeux, en dehors des jeux vidéos évidemment, auxquelles on peut jouer à 2
et qui sont quand même intéressant
Et d'une manière générale, c'est une vraie difficulté de trouver des jeux à 2
C'est une difficulté pas pour tout le monde
pas pour mon pote JS, vous vous souvenez de
Jean Sébastien Masset,
qui vous a fait un tour de cartes, assez récemment sur ma chaîne YouTube
JS aussi c'est un joueur
Il adore ça, il adore jouer. Laure aussi sa compagne, sa femme. Ils se sont mariés
J'étais invité
Ils m'ont offert
Un jeu. Ça s'appelle
Mister Jack
c'est sur Jack L'éventreur
Je vous le fais voir
Dans Mr Jack, vous avez un plateau. Le style de plateau qu'on connait bien dans les jeux de plateau justement
avec des cases en hexagonales
qui permettent des connexions à 6 cases autour d'elle
et une temporalité définie
Ça c'est le nombre de tour qui va y avoir dans le jeu
Il va y avoir 8 tours au maximum
donc quoi qu'il arrive la partie, elle aura une durée à peu près similaire d'une fois à l'autre
Alors encore une fois il y a 2 possibilités pour les joueurs
Y a vraiment 2 rôles distinct, chacun va choisir l'un des 2 rôles évidemment
et puis à la partie d'après on peut switcher, c'est ça qui est intéressant
Voici le concept du jeu, nous sommes dans le centre ville de Londres
et comme vous pouvez le voir, ou pas, il fait déjà nuit et Jack l'éventreur a encore frappé
Et là, je peux vous dire que toute la police de Scotland Yard, de partout
c'est mis en tête d'arrêter Jack L'éventreur
et ce qu'ils savent pas encore c'est que Jack l'éventreur est parmi eux
donc on a pleins de personnages plus ou moins emblématique
Comme Watson ou Lestrade, ou Sherlock Holmes etc...
Ils vont être placés sur le plateau en début du jeu
C'est pas aléatoire, ça c'est déjà défini au départ
Et à chaque tour dans un ordre défini par les règles et tout est symbolisé ici
Il y a rien à retenir alors ça c'est vraiment très pratique
les joueurs vont pouvoir déplacer certains des jetons, certains des personnages
Un des 2 joueurs sait qui est Jack L'éventreur
et il doit faire en sorte que Jack puisse
soit ne pas être arrêter à la fin des 8 tours, au lever du soleil,
soit que Jack puisse s'enfuir du centre ville de Londres, pour tous les semer et s'échapper
L'autre joueur va représenter les forces de l'ordre.
Il veut, absolument, arrêter Jack l'éventreur, donc déjà identifier qui est Jack et l'arrêter, l'empêcher de fuir
ou l'arrêter avant le lever du soleil
A chaque tour, les joueurs bougent certains personnages dans un ordre qui est pré-défini
Les personnages sont choisis au hasard avec des cartes et
chaques personnages a un pouvoir spécifique
par exemple Watson a une lanterne
et avec sa lanterne il peut voir, sauf si il y a un obstacle, dans toute la direction de son faisceau en fait,
il peut éclairer quelqu'un
parce que comme je vous les dit, il fait nuit
et il fait nuit, d'ailleurs moi aussi il fait de plus en plus nuit, ça veut dire qu'il est quelle heure ?!
Ça veut dire qu'il faut que j'active un petit peu
à la fin de chaque tour, sur les 8 tours, le joueur qui représente les forces de l'ordre qui doit arrêter Jack l'éventreur
va poser la question suivante à l'autre joueur:
Est ce que Jack est dans la lumière? Est ce que Jack est éclairé ou non?
Si, il est éclairé le joueur qui veut sauver Jack
on veut sauver un criminel, Bravo!
va mettre cette carte là dans cette position lumineuse,
sinon, il va la mettre dans la position sombre
il y a tout un système de lampadaire qui s'allume, qui s'éteint au fur et à mesure
Et si on est sur une case proche du lampadaire ou si on est éclairé par la carte de Watson,
on est, de ce fait, dans la lumière
Alors, vous allez me dire, mais dans ces cas là c'est très simple il faut mettre tout le monde dans l'ombre
pas forcément parce que, comme
le choix des personnages à bouger est aléatoire
et comme l'ordre des mouvements par les joueurs est défini à l'avance par les règles du jeu
alors ça sera jamais possible de mettre tout le monde dans la lumière ou tout le monde dans l'ombre
donc les 2 joueurs doivent anticiper à l'avance un peu comme aux échecs
on va dire c'est des échecs beaucoup plus ludique, et bien plus simplifier
mais les joueurs doivent anticiper les coups sur ce qui va se passer
au final c'est ça. C'est un jeu qui paraît très très simple dans les règles
mais en fait qu'il l'es. Les règles sont très simple. Y'a pas beaucoup de choses à retenir parce que tout est reporté ici.
Y'a plus qu'à suivre le jeu
Mais toutes les stratégies, qu'on peut élaborer, sont mortelles
surtout grâce à la temporalité
Ça fait tic tac, tic tac, au bout de 8 tours, la partie elle est terminée
donc il faut se bouger, il faut tenter des trucs. Faut réfléchir assez vite
Le tour par tour est bien fait
Ça s'appelle Jack, Merci JS de me l'avoir offert
Je vous le recommande vraiment
C'est la fin de cette vidéo, je ne sais pas combien de temps, j'ai filmé.
Je sais pas combien de temps j'ai mis à la faire
j'espère que ces vidéos là, vont être une respiration un peu dans la semaine
comme ça, il y aura les expériences de mentalisme que je fais sur les gens que je rencontre
les petites astuces que je donne le mercredi
les samedis où c'est un peu plus solide on va dire
avec les Master Class'
et les dimanches où je vous explique quelque chose  pour bluffer vos proches
Je me dis que là, on devrait avoir une chaîne bien fourni
Le MentalVlog c'est une vidéo par jour, vous vous le savez mais est ce que vos amis le savent
est ce que vous êtes abonnés? Non!
Abonnez vous à la chaîne
Ramenez du monde pour les abonnés aussi à 2500 abonnés
C'est l'objectif, je vous rappelle,
Objectif 2500
On se fera tout un échange pour se parler en même temps pour se connecter en même temps. On va se donner un RDV
On va pouvoir faire pleins de choses durant 2 ou 3 heures
Si cette vidéo vous a plu penser à...
mettre un pouce en l'air, Oui !
mais surtout à la partager pour faire découvrir ces jeux à d'autres personnes
Et moi demain je mentaliserais Karim Duval alors RDV demain à 17h sur cette chaîne YouTube
Ciao!